[Music]
welcome back to hot seat the show with
the hot seat and and and also the hots
questions today we have bart quan
oh no okay it's scary being here it's
the first time i'm here and it's kind of
scary scary right now dude taiko's been
there dude you got to focus up here
i don't know you have like a little
bobby pins
that's all folks and to start it off
usually we have you starting it off with
the coldest of the coldest questions ask
yourself what
we're going to have ryan do it this time
if that's okay
i'll do a bart style yeah yeah what
would you think is the most good
unnecessary
south american language venezuelan what
the [ __ ] how come but it's all spanish
that's a cold question no venezuela is
the
whole language in the dumpster
brazilians speak portuguese dialect of
venezuelan is useless
because if you you could always borrow a
little bit from ecuador and borrow a
little bit from colombia and you can
kind of understand what everyone's
saying and the whole the whole like
sandal shape wow sandal shape he just
made that up he just made it up like he
makes up when he asks the question
and you can hear it
what paper towel company would you be
would you be one ply or two ply mad libs
himself
how often do you shave once a year no
honestly burn have a schedule don't make
fun of me and schedules okay okay
it's coming
um
i i honestly shave every
uh
sunday night and every wednesday night
why is it because in between why
um well because
my my jk news is always thursday through
friday or thursday through saturday so i
hate thinking about [ __ ] because i just
like to be free so if i just set times
that i do it then i know i'll always be
like camera ready do you have like an
alarm or something that tells you shave
time no i've done it for so long i think
it's part of my circadian rhythm you
know that it's a wednesday yeah like
wednesday night i'm like shave time
what's the last oh sorry what's the last
time that you scheduled something that
you knew you were being bart ridiculous
about
what does that mean
something that didn't need to be
scheduled even bart recognized like man
that's kind of stupid he schedules when
he busts the nut and sex dude
you've been so
even something that i find really yeah
yeah i don't find any of it ridiculous
sex scheduling there's not even more
yeah exactly you scheduled sex with yeah
we know that you how do you how do you
schedule it anyway also once a year well
so she's busy too and then now we have a
kid so you got a third person equation
so it's like don't do tycoon you're sexy
you can't just have sex [ __ ] at seven
p.m when tyco's eating dinner and [ __ ]
that's weird who says you can
and i guess you can uh we did try it
when when he was taking a nap but then
have to be keep the couch from rocking
too hard because then he's sleeping
right there and then also felt weird
because you're looking around or
whatever in the moment and then you're
like
wow
true
um the weirdest
scheduling thing
man you really don't find any of it
ridiculous okay
i really don't know good to know i like
it because it helps me i believe you i
don't want you to have to make something
up it helps me he always makes something
up though
the one time he doesn't make something
up uh so so we're going to triple the
heat a little bit
we just started no no
just a little bit just a little bit
we're not going to yeah this isn't the
main one don't we just give you a knife
you can stab me in the ass i know i
didn't say it no
um so so recently you want us to so so
recently you had a contest
um and i'm just gonna pull up a picture
of this contest what's the contest so
this contest
hey what is this this guy's prepared
train with bart uh-huh he was training
was bart yep yep yep
you get to work out with them you win
the contest the month of april you get
to train with bart yep okay and speaking
of scheduling we picked three winners so
here let me just read this real quick
and then um and then i want to gauge the
room they wanna [ __ ] train with you
all of us are friends and we don't want
to train with you well that's a good
argument but but i think that training
the part i can see how people are
pretending you guys either how do i
[ __ ] train with you to get my ass
[ __ ] kicked no no listen to this
listen to this
okay uh if you win right we'll meet at
9am
that's not what it says you're [ __ ]
like i said with me at 9am
that's how i know you did you got this
[ __ ] photoshopped what are you talking
about this is [ __ ] you you you posted
to somebody you posted it dude oh you
know i think i wrote that actually yeah
what the [ __ ] i know you did because
because i want you to listen are you
ready yeah this is why bart needs to run
his [ __ ] by his friends
because bart wrote this i knew you did
by the way okay check this out that's my
schedule he says we'll meet
at 9 00 a.m
train from 10 a.m to 12 p.m see okay
nothing unusual so you get to hang out
for an hour well those people roll in
different times a little bit 30 minutes
late especially their vietnamese or
whatever it makes sense
i'm always early lunch from noon
to one lunch from noon to one yeah we
try and we eat okay now here's my
favorite part
personal q a from one to two yeah so
because a lot of these people from out
of town they have a bunch of questions
to ask they're like don't be asking me
questions while we're lifting weights
that's exactly right we meet at 9am
don't [ __ ] talk to me to the personal
q a that is from one to two no [ __ ]
questions no [ __ ] questions dude you
trying to hang out with people for five
hours and then they ask only in the
fifth
give some time to think about it's just
more intention it's like when we're
working out it's like conversational but
then you know people are always like oh
look i got
my sister's as hot as anthony's sister
save that for once that happens every
time right squat or something
he's all squatting he's all like oh one
of my challenges is i want a [ __ ]
ball on anthony's sister but hey hey hey
hey
hey he's the hot seat
that's true that's fair yeah no we just
try to give it a little bit more it's
loose but we just try to get a little
more direction so that like it feels
structured okay yeah
so do you hate me now no i don't hate
you for it buddy it's just [ __ ]
hilarious for me it's hilarious to read
as your friend i'm like of course what
else is on schedule oh then you return
to barbell by three so it's a very
normal day but the fact that you can't
ask him questions for five hours it's
[ __ ] so if you guys win and you're
watching this don't ask until one okay i
don't even [ __ ] talk to him until
what you got five hours to formulate
your questions the winners are gonna be
announced in a few weeks too no q a's
what do you mean i thought i made this
up
what do you mean you said i made this
whole [ __ ] graphic up but i read it
and that's oh yeah i wrote that i forgot
i wrote how are you choosing the winners
uh just do random it was just like a fun
like for the month of april every
purchase you get to enter in a chance to
like train with me or whatever so it was
it's just like we'll just go through the
theme like like a slot machine nice okay
okay all right so uh have you uh ever
wanted to like [ __ ] slap taika [ __ ]
it all the time what the [ __ ]
what was the latest time yeah that's
every parent i feel like i actually did
do it once i felt so [ __ ] in a
[ __ ] face what'd you do it was uh
this is when he was bro you you want to
[ __ ] make him fly look at that
it wasn't hard this was like i forgot
one or two or something
and uh it was like
i don't even remember what happened i
was feeding him
and then
i don't it was like one of those like
you don't when you tickle you you
flinch yeah you flip you tickle dude you
went pop [ __ ] you know what he
did
either like he spit in my eye or
something but it was automatic it was
like that and as soon as that happened
i'm like oh my [ __ ] god i felt so
[ __ ] bad so whatever like extra
precaution i have
um i'm just like oh [ __ ] i gotta like if
i feel out of control of the situation
like if it's parenting or whatever i
always like go and take a breather and
let you handle it i just felt so bad
yeah what would you say because you're
you're a guy who gets to work out a lot
of his [ __ ]
anxiety and your stress and [ __ ] what
would you say you stress about the most
when i stress about the most you can't
say joe yeah
i [ __ ] stress bro because we already
know we already know i can relieve
stress what do i stress about the most
that's a good question
um i think probably
like
what my life will be like
within the next
10 years i think yeah yeah but after
that you don't stress it's like 10 years
no because i think like he's on schedule
11 years he's fine yeah because honestly
the way that i i have like this uh what
is it called
um
my my method for like troubleshooting or
anxiety gauging i call it the abc xyz
method whereas like let's say if i come
into a room right how do i meet people
oh you shake their hands say hi off from
a glass of water that's like abc and
what's the worst case scenario oh i have
to kill them or whatever
i have those
from the beginning like worst case
scenario best case scenario covered then
everything else is fine yeah and then so
i think with my life and like having a
family i think i have like so i have
savings it'll cover me for like six
months to a year i also have pretty good
retirement now and then i have uh we
have a house so i think all the blocks
or buckets of my life are pretty covered
yeah except for the next 10 years got it
so that's that gray area so you don't
know where 50 i'm [ __ ] set you know
but then it's just from here from like
40 to 50
i think i'm still relying on my current
career on what i'm doing to fill in that
space and that's like 12 years then
maybe 12 years yeah and is it because
it's because your current career is
still a lot of work that that's that's
where you're like okay i would have to
have it less by then yeah i feel like
for everything that i have going on it's
like if the engine isn't going then it
goes
it slows down versus some
[Music]
i feel like as soon as i like don't go
like choo choo
how much how much cold cash you got to
have in the bank for you to like not
worry about the next 12 years where you
feel like
yeah
in one account or the total or what
today's video is brought to you by
upstart saying goodbye to high interest
credit card debt is one of the first
steps toward financial independence but
the interest month after month can feel
like you're in this never ending hamster
wheel that's where upstart comes in
upstart powered personal loans can help
you pay down high interest debt all
online with simple and easy to
understand payment terms upstart has
helped over 1.8 million customers on
their path to financial freedom whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses upstart can
help you get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date upstart knows
you're more than just your credit score
so rather than just looking at your
credit score alone upstart's model
considers other factors like your income
employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
you can check your rate in minutes for
loans between one thousand and fifty
thousand dollars without impacting your
credit score you can even receive funds
as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan don't wait and check
your rate today at upstart.com off the
record that's upstart.com off the record
to check your rate today don't forget to
use our url to let them know that we
sent you loan amounts will be determined
based off your credit income and certain
other information provided on your loan
application go to upstart.com off the
record
i'm just [ __ ] go there
oh total which account
international included i don't know
maybe like a million or something just a
million for 12 years
i'm retirement right i have so an
additional millionaire
i have the [ __ ] the bitcoin i dropped
like crazy
i got those things then we have a house
so i'm like
certain buckets are filled here and
there's just the the next 12 years it's
still like oh it's really dependent on
like my my efforts still so if a million
dollars got air dropped on you right now
then you'd be like okay i'm gucci yeah
okay got it a million
yeah probably and you're just like i'm
chill cause you could do enough with it
so now i'm like okay from now until i'm
[ __ ] 100 i'm set
it's just it's just it's like it's like
you you have a car that gets this cliff
and it's just from this cliff to this
club there's no bridge yet but then you
know once you pass that cliff it's
smooth sailing again damn i don't think
we should tell them about inflation
does that do
because you're [ __ ] lose eight
percent a year minimal yeah but he knows
about doge
he's got a bunch of retirement uh
oh right it's like those uh those index
fund type things so it kind of just goes
with this sick all right so we're at the
11 minute 23 second mark where we
already said that six minutes no no he's
just turning up the heat a little bit
this is this is the moment we're really
trying to you turn it up
you're not facilitating man you're in
the host of you okay i'm fine i [ __ ]
my mom in the dream is that what you
want to hear
how many times he told us that that was
disgusting but go ahead he said he woke
up and he vomited i did
over that dream
wow
wow um when was the most pissed you've
ever been at joe
at joe i don't think i've ever been
pissed that joe the [ __ ] is wrong with
him a little bit like a little bit when
was the most pissed joe's ever been at
you
there was one time
[Laughter]
there was one time
i remember where i was i don't know
where you were but we were texting and
it was i think it was about jk news
merch or some [ __ ] do you remember i
don't know man i get mad it was about
this it's the one and only time though
yeah joe has never been mad at me and
then it was a jk news merch thing and
then uh joe's never talked to me like
this and then he goes man [ __ ] it then
do whatever the [ __ ] you want
and then i was like
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] so i called them
i'm like yo what's going on like like i
thought we were just talking about
stupid-ass designs
and then he was like nah you know how
you do that [ __ ] [ __ ] where you just
like you keep persisting over and over
i'm like oh yeah cause i do i know i
have that
he goes yeah dude just [ __ ] going i
just like he just felt like he kept
pushing for the sake of pushing he goes
so i don't even know i thought we're
doing this but now that's so funny like
if you just want to do that then just do
that then i'm like oh [ __ ] my bad i
thought i was being collaborative but i
don't think i was and then it was a good
joke mad impression yeah yeah yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] it's so weird to imagine
that you're gonna do that just do that
then i've heard that before
other
but i forget so
but he's also never raised his voice at
me though yeah that's true only that one
time i was in text in text he raised his
voice in text
there's a lot of [ __ ] every other word
now and i was like oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] going on
and then gio was in that chat too
because you know she was uh she was
trying oh i remember now jill was like
see
friend knows it too you son of a [ __ ]
i like how she immediately had joe's
back yeah yeah yeah she was so funny she
was coordinating um me and joe are
brainstorming the jk news like logos or
whatever designs and she was supposed to
execute it so she's just bringing it up
so me and him to talk it out
and then it ended up being like joe
blowing up in there and just remember
joe's in the chat too
what would you say is the hardest thing
you've had to go through
the hardest thing
the hardest thing we had to go uh as
like a jk as a company or just you as a
man oh as a man
man i've been through so much [ __ ] let
me see don't say your [ __ ] deadlift
dog
[Laughter]
my recent shoulder injury and i couldn't
do face pulls with him he's like man i
was [ __ ] pulling and pulling and it
was like oh yeah my shoulder went out
and i was like ah i [ __ ] missed the
lift and i set a goal and i was like i
can't hit that goal now it's gonna take
me 18 more days so the okay this is the
hardest thing i have to go through you
know when you have trauma and you start
burying it like crazy and you start uh
like covering it up
subconsciously with some sort of like
with your own defense mechanisms yeah
and it gets so far to the point where
you forgot
where the trauma is and you're just
living the new life so um i think back
in 2015 or something or 2016
me and jill are going through like a
pretty rough time
so the only logical like
therapy is to take a lot of ecstasy and
just talk it out
and then on one of them um we're just
talking about all kinds of stuff because
you just get supe super vulnerable uh
vulnerable from it
i was like flashback you know and
ratatouille when he eats it he goes
yeah and he goes back to me as a kid
there there's this one time it flashed
back to me i think being like 11 or
something and i remember
i was hiding in the couch because there
was like these group of dudes i was
hiding next to the couch at my house
because there's this group of dudes that
wanted to [ __ ] me up and i was uh
really scared when they came to your
house that's your own house so i think
it was one of those things where like in
fifth grade and sixth grade i think
that's when boys start getting really
rowdy oh yeah right and then you're like
oh you think we'll [ __ ] him up oh yeah
you think i'll [ __ ] him up and then i'm
just [ __ ] around with people i'm like
oh yeah oh danielle [ __ ] him up or
whatever he'll [ __ ] him up and then not
knowing summertime
these two dudes all of a sudden have
[ __ ] puberty and they're just huge
and they're i'm like watching [ __ ]
like like [ __ ] x-men at home
like pre-pubescent right [ __ ] just
sitting there enjoying [ __ ] uh
spider-man or uh x-men or whatever and i
just hear
and then i can hear bart you the f-word
of course i know you're in there
whatever and i was like
holy [ __ ] and they would start throwing
rocks at the window and they were
banging out the door it was just me by
myself and i was scared and i was like
hiding in the couch and then i remember
um
after they left
i felt like such a little [ __ ]
that i never ever
ever wanted to feel like that again like
i felt like my life wasn't in my control
so i think from then on is when i really
got into like martial arts and lifting
and doing all that stuff he went kung fu
out of all things no i did come for
before that oh okay and then i um i
didn't realize uh
and then i think you just start building
a night a new identity so i didn't
realize that there was at one point
where i felt so vulnerable and so like
ashamed of myself until we took ecstasy
and then i was like boom that's like
terry crews man he wanted to
be strong because you know when people
ask like oh like how did you get into
lifting or you know doing that kind of
stuff and it was just like oh yeah my
homies older brothers taught me
i mean that's how it happened but then
there's also the homies that kicked it
in the same garage
but not everyone's lifting weights the
other half were just sitting there
smoking cigarettes or whatever right and
then like so that the why it happened it
came to me where did you start like the
next day or when did you start
um i don't remember if i did
um
but i think i felt really like no one
even knows because it was summertime it
wasn't like you go back to school and
people talk [ __ ] right or whatever but
so no one even knows but i just remember
feeling like
so ashamed like the whole song but you
couldn't stand up and fight i actually
just went out and got my ass beat and at
least took it to hide like the little
[ __ ] behind the couch
yeah well hiding like a [ __ ] probably
is really the subconscious birth of
barbell brigade so you should thank
those two guys dominating i'm gonna
change the logo to a red couch
a red velvet cat and a small child
hiding behind it [ __ ] couch brigade
[Laughter]
i remember when we were doing mma show i
was like man why you [ __ ] lift so
much and you're like man all i want to
do is [ __ ] punch somebody through a
window
grab a dude and pull him out of the car
and i was like oh that's a good leap
that's a good reason man
that's a really good reason it's our
lipstick i already forgot you know
that's already what like 10 years and
you thought that was your reason yeah
yeah you just don't remember because you
just have so many layers built up do you
have like a super goal right now like
something where it's like yeah i'm doing
that [ __ ] now it's no longer a car it's
like an airplane window or some [ __ ]
while you're flying in the air dang
you're like the fast and the furious it
just keeps going up
space shuttle's next geo out of a
helicopter the production budget just
goes up now it's a new motivation a
super goal in terms of life or anything
you want um i do want to do a movie like
that's i think the main reason why all
this stuff started
so it's one of those things where like
if if it doesn't happen when i'm 30 and
it'll happen when i'm 40 it doesn't
happen that'll happen on 50 but for sure
making a movie like beginning to end is
something that's i've always wanted to
do let's try it is there a script that
you want to make like there's a bunch we
wrote together
what's your favorite like what's the one
that you're like out of all these that
we did this is the one we're gonna do if
i get that opportunity when you get that
opportunity i don't have like a favorite
one i like all of them if i had to pick
one pick one like let's say someone's
gun your head dude oh then it's the uh
uh
60 seconds one
i like that one it's when the mcdojo man
yeah yeah yeah this is a good one you
must fight in the mma ring yeah i love i
just i like action i like comedy it's
that's like i like the end yeah
there's a lot of really really good
scenes i want to talk about them but
it's probably gonna ruin it or spoil it
you'll probably probably if you're
talking about making when you're 50 i
don't think anyone will remember
but i understand if you had to fire one
of us here and then replace us with an
old person you already fired in the past
who would it be yeah that's really good
pick one dude
well there's so many people that got
fired
so many how do we even count
you know
that's like they all left on horrible
terms too
can't cop out with like a geo or some
[ __ ] dude technically none of them are
fired
julia was fired
oh she was the most fired i was fired we
booted her chinese ass out when she
comes back every couple months
i'll probably replace anthony with josh
maybe
we miss josh though
there you have it guys thanks for
watching the hot seat i'd replace
anthony with and just fill in the blanks
with the random name they didn't have to
have worked here it's always got to be
method
you just want to ask it
i'm here for the fans
you know i
i'm here for the fans
and the free gas money and food i would
trade anthony for ted from wong fu are
you here for the fans huh you son of a
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
strategically placed gingerbread it's
upside down
yeah i'm sorry sorry then arms rejection
i accidentally left on that son of a
[ __ ] you could have grabbed the tabasco
the red bull the kirkland water you know
what you wanted held up you know you
you